- YOU HAVE SINNED AGAINST
THE ANIMAL KINGDOM,
AN ACT PUNISHABLE BY DEATH.
- WE'RE PARK RANGERS.
EVERYTHING WE DO AT THIS PARK
IS TO KEEP ANIMALS SAFE.
- YEAH! GET HIM!
BITE THAT MOTHER[bleep]!
[crunch]
WHOO! I WON!
GIVE ME MY GODDAMN MONEY.
[sentimental piano music]
♪
[munching]
- THIS ISN'T THAT BAD.
WHAT IS THIS?
- A BEAVER'S ASSHOLE.
- [vomits]
[water splashes]
THIS IS A LOW POINT.
[moose bellows]
[bear roars]
[moose whimpers]
WOW, THANK YOU.
YOU SAVED MY LIFE.
I DO NOT KNOW HOW I COULD REPA--
[iPhone chimes]
HOLD ON.
- O-M-F-G. I MISS U.
EMOTICON SAD FACE.
I NEVER R-O-T-F-L-M-F-A-O
ANYMORE.
I LESS-THAN SIGN THREE YOU.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE OUT,
I'M GAY IF YOU ARE.
[iPhone chimes]
NO! I MEAN, IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE UP, I'M GAME IF YOU ARE.
GODDAMN AUTOCORRECT!